welcome to the Khan Academy daily
homeroom this is a way that we're trying
to stay in touch and help support
parents teachers and students as we go
through this school closure situation
many of y'all know Khan Academy were
not-for-profit with a mission of
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere and we could have
never predicted the scenario we're now
in this very suboptimal situation but
over the last 10 years or so we've been
building resources that now can really
help you as a student a parent or a
teacher bridge make sure that everyone
can keep learning through this through
this crisis I I do want to remind folks
that we are not-for-profit we are funded
by philanthropic donations from folks
like yourself so if you're in a position
to do so please think about donating to
Khan Academy you can see some links on
this screen right over here I do want to
do give a special shout out to several
core
our gap we were running at a deficit
even before this crisis started and now
our usage is about two hundred fifty
percent of normal and so you could
imagine our budget situation has gotten
leave it a little bit more serious so
special thanks to Bank of America which
is really the first to step up that
first weekend when the school closures
were happening we were seeing that
traffic spike followed closely by 18t
google.org and Novartis so whether
you're an individual or someone who
represents a corporation we still need
help we're still running at a deficit
and we have a lot of ideas of what we
would like to do to support more folks
through this crisis but we are somewhat
gated by resources at the moment now the
fun of this session is it's really we
want to make it as interactive as
possible so whatever social media you're
watching this on whether it's Facebook
or YouTube or someplace else we're
always adding new things to it feel free
ask questions on the discussion board
and this is a forum very informal
literally ask anything I would like to
be surprised no question will offend us
and it's fun to discuss not just how
Khan Academy resources might be used or
how we might navigate this crisis or
implications in education these are all
very interesting topics but I'm also
happy to answer questions about other
things that are interesting to you or
maybe sometimes we want to talk about
things other than Kovan right now but we
can obviously talk about that as well
and I have team members on Khan Academy
and Dan who will join us and know their
stand right over there who will help
myself and Dan and some of our team
members are going to be looking at the
comments as they come in and so we will
answer any questions that you might have
and so if I look if and we have a duet
we do have a few announcement that we've
been making over the last couple of days
one of them is we've we released these
schedules about three four weeks ago
that first weekend when the closures
were happening and we got a lot of
feedback from parents to students and
teachers that they would want even more
a detailed resources so above and beyond
the live stream the schedules the
webinars were running we released
learning plans for students to keep them
learning through the summer not through
not just through the end of the school
year but also leveraging some
for time of learning and so these are if
you go to our main I guess kovat
response center you can see the URLs on
the screen you will see these new
learning plans and depending on whether
your third grade fourth grade fifth
grade all the way up through algebra and
algebra two and geometry a week by week
goals for getting mastery on Khan
Academy so highly encourage folks to
check that out and keep learning over a
break and so let's see we have we're
getting trying to get some questions one
from YouTube Anuj Bhagwan says hey Sal
what motivates you to always push the
limits well I'm always pushing the
limits but I think the things that Khan
Academy is working on and our mission
and what we aspire to do there's urgency
to it you have even before this kovat
crisis you have hundreds of millions of
students around the world arguably
billions who have access to some form of
schooling but could use more supports
you have millions of teachers around the
world who know that they want to support
their students in better ways but it's
difficult if you're a teacher in a
classroom of 30 students and every
student has their own different learning
needs as learning in a different pace
they need tools to be able to support
them and all of these things of you know
how do you allow more people to have
access to world-class resources how do
you create better tools for teachers how
do you connect that to opportunity that
exists in the real world and without you
know higher education or internships or
jobs those were always important and
they've just now become a lot more
important because of this kovat crisis
so I speak for myself and I speak for a
lot of the team members and a lot of the
folks supporting Khan Academy there's an
urgency here that you know I always
think about for every Albert Einstein we
know about or every Marie Curie we know
about how many others we're never able
to fulfill their potential and that's a
shame even on an individual level that
they could have maybe done so much more
and it's also a shame for Humanity
because that person could have found the
cure for a disease or could have found a
way to solve a major issue in our
society and I suspect that for every
Albert or
Burda Einstein we we discover
historically there's probably been 50 or
100 that we don't discover that never
got the educational opportunities never
got to tap into their potential and so
if Khan Academy can be part of the
solution to increase by an order of
magnitude by a factor of 10 the number
that we can discover and not just those
you know very special circumstances like
an Albert Einstein but the whole
distribution so more people can
participate in the economy we're
definitely getting into a world with
automation that you need higher level
skills in order to participate we know
what's happening with robotics with
computing that's going to be able to do
a lot of the skills that labor has
cystic historically done and so as we
get more productive we have two choices
we either have to get all of humanity to
be able to participate in the knowledge
economy and I hope Khan Academy could
play a role there or we're going to have
tougher times and obviously what's going
on economically now makes that even
clearer so let's see other questions
that I'm getting I'm having a my regular
mouse is a little strange right now so
please bear with me a little bit so
there is Facebook neon Khan asked Sal
can you speak Bengali for me please any
of my Bengali family members will cringe
if I start to speak Bengali can through
I mean volta party on my accent
kuba ba GA h AR Drone ami on ik bangla
bully knock into you know I mean Chester
Corey so for those of you who do not
know Bengali I just said I can speak
Bengali I can get by but my accent is
really bad but I I try I'm sorry I think
I just made about 400 million Bengali
speakers around the world cringe but
that's I guess you know that nyan asked
for that all right so from YouTube
Katherine Pierce asks what's coming to
Kahn Academy next so there's a lot of
things going on at Khan Academy some of
which we have talked about in some of
which we're except we're trying to
accelerate because of this kovat crisis
English and language arts many of y'all
are familiar we
just launched what's known as a beta
version in software world beta is like
it's a it's it's not even quite a first
version it's a version that you put out
there to start to learn about how it's
used how what's good about it what's not
it's we know it's not a perfect version
a lot of the a lot of the modalities on
Khan Academy were first made for the
math and sciences and so you could
imagine when we try to put reading
comprehension into that same modality
sometimes it's a little bit awkward
ideally in reading comprehension it's
not just a question and a passage in a
question and then another passage in a
question you want a passage and then
four or five questions like we do in our
SAT practice so we're working on
hopefully over the next many months
improving things like that we are
continuing to partner with districts and
we might be accelerating that over the
course of this crisis because more and
more districts are thinking about how do
they keep students learning and times of
school closures and that's on top of the
need that districts have always
recognized that they administer
standardized tests they see that
students some students are ready for
grade-level work some students have a
lot of gaps in their knowledge some
students are ready to move ahead but
they've historically not had a good way
of of differentiating and tools like
Khan Academy could be helpful there so
we're working with districts to provide
things like district dashboards and
rostering with them we hope to continue
to you'll be seeing our chemistry
content is getting significantly fleshed
out we are constantly improving our math
content we are hoping to add even more
subjects we're talking to
philanthropists about wouldn't it be
great if we could fund middle school
science and things like that and so
that's pure philanthropist please
contact us if you're interested in
funding things like that longer term
we're thinking about simple ways to help
place and diagnose folks on Khan Academy
so right now we have a lot of the
resources that you can start as early as
pre-k with Khan Academy kids you can see
Cody right behind me gazing over my
shoulder but we have most of the content
from pre-k all the way through
elementary middle and high school for
sure in math and science but
increasingly in the humanities and
English and language arts but because
there's so much content sometimes folks
like where do I start what do I do if
maybe I'm in a certain grade but I have
so maybe I'm in a certain grade I'm
ready to move ahead or I already know
some of the material and we've been
putting out material during this crisis
about how to use our mass for your
mechanics if you think you already know
some of sixth grade go take the course
challenge and then you and when you
start seeing diminishing returns there
go take the unit test etc etc but we
want to make it more we want to put that
in the experience better make it a
little bit easier for people to
understand where they can go and what
types of courses maybe we can curate for
certain for those different cases so the
simple answer is we just want to add a
lot of content a lot more content we
want to and we want to make it a lot
more a lot easier to use find what you
need to work on a lot more engaging we
have some I hope we can get this for
back-to-school but we definitely have
some team members who are thinking about
how to make the navigation on the site a
lot easier so we definitely have our
work cut out a lot there because we're
literally trying to cover 13 years of
all of the core academic subjects and
build tools for teachers and support
classrooms simultaneously we have 59
translation projects around the world so
we are also thinking about how we can
support other geographies in particular
places like Brazil and India where we
actually have an Peru where we actually
have team members there who are helping
drive a Khan Academy's mission in those
geographies so I'm sure I'm missing
things but that's some of what Academy
has going forward
hey Sal Adnan Ibis conch wala from
YouTube asks Sal what's one thing you
want to master while being at home one
thing I want to master while being at
home I think I'm trying to master
balancing life and work I don't know if
that's you wanted a meta-level answer
like that but you could imagine now at
school closures my kids are home and I
said they said other at other live
streams I think all of us were
especially you know in some group my job
at Khan Academy has gotten busier
there's more to do to the previous
question I feel more urgency than ever
to try to get some of this stuff done
that we've been talking about for a very
long time but if your five year old you
know is screaming or wants your
attention
you're it's it's a tough tension and I
don't feel sorry for myself because I
know
there's millions of parents around the
world that are going through at least
what I'm going through probably far
worse I have a lot of supports at home
my my wife my mother-in-law we've all
been trying to you know tag-team this
and frankly they've been I've been able
to lean on them now that even more even
though my wife has a full-time job as
well and but because of all the Khan
Academy thing picking up so I think
mastering that balance is something that
a lot of parents are struggling with
right now and one thing that's clicked
in my head recently is you know as much
urgency as I feel towards my job and as
much urgency as I feel towards work you
know those are moments you don't want to
let go of when you're when your
eight-year-old when she asks for help or
she wants to show something that she
made or she has a question for you that
because that time their childhood goes
by very fast so I'm I'm trying to just
make sure that I can enjoy that and and
give them the time they need while also
making sure that Khan Academy is able to
continue to support our many many many
people right now that's yeah I think
that's the the biggest thing you know
I've had a lifelong quest to - I guess
you'd call it a Fitness quest there's a
lotta things on a diet and a nutritional
side that I've I've been trying to to
master but sometimes I fall off the
wagon
so from youtube Mach par asks did you
expect Khan Academy to be this
successful mock yes and no I got a you
know when I when I was a kid and maybe
not even so much a kid even when I was
in my 20s and Khan Academy was a you
know I was tutoring my cousin's there's
definitely a part of me and it's still
there that I daydream a lot and I
definitely would have these moments
where I'm like hey this thing that I'm
tutoring my cousin's and if I make tools
for them maybe it's scales and if it's
useful for them maybe it could be useful
for millions or billions of people one
day and wouldn't it be cool if one day
there was a new type of institution
where anyone on the planet had access to
learning and yeah I've cited being
inspired by books like Isaac Asimov's
Foundation series where in that book you
know galactic civilization and someone
creates a foundation at the
the Empire to shorten a thousands of
year galactic dark ages and I remember
always being inspired by saying yeah
knowledge is the thing that can most
support society and keep us from I guess
falling apart and and and devolving so
to speak and so I've always thought
those kind of I guess you could say
grand thoughts but then usually after I
let myself go on one of those those
visions for five or ten minutes of exile
be realistic just put one foot in front
of the other just do the next you know
the next right thing to quote frozen to
and and move from there and so I would
kind of then just get very very
practical I could have never imagined
that when I was tutoring my cousin's 13
14 years ago or when I quit my day job
about 10 or 11 years ago that it would
have truly evolved as fast as it has but
I always did keep that somewhat
delusional thing in the back of my mind
of like well maybe this could be like a
Smithsonian or a great university or or
even operated to scale a hundred or a
thousand times larger than that and now
that Khan Academy is is is of a larger
scale and you know what this kovat
crisis it is playing a I guess you could
say an institutional role here for
millions of folks tens of millions of
folks around the world I'm a little less
bashful speaking openly about these
aspirations of it becoming a
multi-generational institution that can
empower billions of folks over time so I
still try to balance and I think light
you know that's the interesting thing
about life you're always trying to
balance making sure you know putting one
leg in front of the other and not
getting too far ahead of yourself and
and staying humble thank Lee with having
big goals big visions and not being
afraid to you know use a baseball
analogy swing for the fences and so
that's always been my hope for Khan
Academy but you know I got to say even
today as far as Khan Academy has gone
I'm always my stress level can sometimes
be pretty high because I'm like we can't
blow it now we have to go much further
to empower so many more today and more
questions yes so from YouTube Ashutosh
Tiwari asks hi so many people
trying to start a YouTube channel and
make tutorials just like you especially
during this crisis but not everybody is
Salman Khan what advice would you give
for someone actually this question sad
we also get from a lot of teachers who
are having to do remote teaching right
now and they would love your advice in
terms of just how to present online you
know my number one advice a lot of times
folks end up focusing on the optics and
you know does it look professional
versus I would say the authenticity and
the human element of it and my number
one advice to anyone making content
whether they're doing it kind of
aniconic a de mie style with a pen
tablet or they're just doing a video
like this is be yourself be you laugh at
yourself don't be afraid to make
mistakes
be is that that authentic as possible
human beings can know when someone else
is not themselves when they're not being
authentic when they're reading a script
and you might be reading a script for a
very good reason you want to get all
your language precise et cetera et
cetera but I think there's a nice
balance you want to have the right
vocabulary you want to get your language
right but there's something powerful
about the the learner seeing that you
are working it through them you're truly
thinking through it with them I think
another point of advice is to view you
know I've heard from some teachers it's
hard to teach to the screen because you
might be used to other folks in the room
and and this is where you know maybe my
daydreaming imagination as has been an
asset I I imagine when I make content I
imagine that I'm talking to my cousins
or my cousins at a certain age or my
family members I think it creates a
connection and I think even though we
are using technology and we're going to
be you know I'm making the content now
and it might be used by thousands of
people at another time they'll feel that
that connection in it another thing I'd
say is try to really focus on the the
connections in concepts too many times
not just in math but pretty much in
every subject concepts are taught in
isolation and even a little comment a
little connection to like well yeah this
is why plastics are stretchy actually
just to just did a video on amorphous
solids so that's why it's front of mine
for me or you know that's why I mean
you know actually one of the fun things
that actually I didn't include in my
video is why why eggs become solid when
you heat it up and that's because the
proteins denature and what would be
these bound proteins these globular
proteins they become these kind of
stringy things and they all call it get
all entangled with each other and so
that's why the egg white gets gets kind
of it kind of becomes an amorphous solid
so to speak but if you could connect
things to the real world if you could
connect things to what people knew
before you know and Khan Academy videos
you'll often hear me say hey you know
this might look like another concept but
it really is just an extension of
completing the square the quadratic
formula is just completing the square
for any quadratic or the quotient rule
in calculus really is just the product
and the chain rules combined so I think
the more that you can connect things to
what learners already know and there's a
lot of learning science behind that as
well that people like to be grounded in
what they already know and and most of
knowledge is that way it is connected to
other things so that's my my best advice
and have fun doing it if you don't have
fun making the content the person
listening to the content is not going to
have fun and if you're not passionate
about the content and excited about it
it's going to be hard for the other
person to be excited about it so one
thing I tell myself and everyone at Khan
Academy who makes content is not just
video content actually even exercises
and things like articles if you're not
excited about it if you don't feel the
energy if you don't see the beauty and
the concept it's going to be very hard
for the student to feel that same thing
and we want them to feel that and the
reality is pretty much every concept has
a beauty to it has an intuitive nough
stew it has a connection to other things
it has connection to the to the real
world so let's see there's a question of
interesting one from angel Chopra from
YouTube are there any positives that
resulted or maybe might result from the
corona virus epidemic well as you could
imagine as we're in the midst of it it's
it's you know it's hard to see sometimes
the silver linings if I were and it's
easy to point to a lot of things that
are stressful or not so great about the
crisis if I were to say some of the
positives or the the silver linings you
know I talked a little earlier about
spending time with
I think a lot of us if we're lucky
enough to be with our families right now
this is time that you know it's it's in
everyday life when we're on the on on
our on doing the daily grind so to speak
it's easy to take family for granted
it's easy to take friends for granted
and now we you know whether it's in
person
I'm I'm able to spend more time with my
kids with my wife we're this is time
we'll never forget and we'll never get
back so I think there's something
powerful there
I think this crisis has there's
something about it that makes us want to
reach out to our family members and be
more connected with them you know I've
talked on this livestream about my mom
she's alone lives alone in New Orleans
right now which is having a very you
know high per capita incidents of kovin
and my mom as you could imagine is in is
in that high-risk group and so just my
worry for her physical health and
frankly her mental health because she's
living by herself now I've told myself
Sally you can't just you say hey I need
to finish this task at work and I'll
call my mom tomorrow you've got to call
your mom every day and have a
conversation with her and it's been
great I've been doing it because of the
crisis but I've kind of realized that I
should be doing this all the time that
it shouldn't just be during the crisis
and we're having good conversations even
though we're 2,000 miles apart better
conversations frankly then you know when
I call every three days or we only chat
once a week so I think that's been
important I've been connecting with
friends and family that I haven't talked
to for five ten years on zoom and Google
Hangouts so those are positives I think
on the education side obviously school
closures are very suboptimal but I'm
hoping that some of the tools that we
might accelerate Khan Academy and others
might accelerate unbilled
to respond to the crisis those will
exist after so that's a silver lining
I'm hoping that some of the habits some
of the patterns that students and
teachers and parents are forming during
the crisis will have lasting benefit if
you as a student are learning hey I can
structure my day I can keep learning I
can do that during the summers I can do
that when I'm an adult I mean even after
I've graduated from high school or
college those are super useful skills
arguably the most important skills that
can last you an entire lifetime we were
just talking about teacher
and other folks making lessons online to
help their students that's great that's
going to have lasting implications
beyond the crisis now that folks realize
how important online access at home is
we're seeing a lot of telecom companies
a philanthropist a ray and Barbara
Dahlia - philanthropist we know who've
been longtime supporters of Khan Academy
they've just distributed 60,000 laptops
in Connecticut to low-income high school
students we're seeing school districts
like alocs vegas/clark county we had dr.
JA Ronn last week talk about how they
are distributing laptops and working
with local cable companies to get Wi-Fi
access or get online access these are
things that I hope could lay a
groundwork that's permanent so that even
once we're past this crisis people will
have that access which is empowering on
so many so many levels I think you know
just the the cracks that we're seeing in
our society you know large numbers of
people due to no fault of their own
aren't able to work now because of they
were working at a restaurant or a travel
agency or an airline all of these things
that even once we get through the worse
of the stay in place orders it's
unlikely that those industries are going
to come back fully we talked about that
last week with Bill Gates III think
that's making all of us recognize and
governments recognize that hey we yeah
we probably do need supports for these
folks because it's for no fault of their
own you know in order to protect the
public safety they're suffering and they
need some ways to some way to support
their their families so regards to where
you're on the political spectrum I think
it's making us all realize that hey
there are some supports that that folks
need so I think all of these types of
things as we go through the crisis will
hopefully have some some positive
lasting implications we could think of
more feel free to add any that you could
think of on the message boards we're
happy to take a look at it so from from
Facebook Samar Abed Rabbo says for
college students do you think that we
should move to more critical thinking
tests that are open book
since the works have changed with so
much access to information some are I
think yes and no I think there are some
times of
you'll hear this and you'll actually
hear this commonly in education circles
oh people can google everything now why
should people know why should people
have you know facts or content knowledge
that they can google that stuff and then
they can just work on the projects or
the applied the critical thinking parts
of it learning science actually tells us
I'm actually reading a book right now
about this kind of a survey of learning
science you know something that we take
very seriously at Khan Academy and the
reality is is that factual knowledge
that content knowledge whether it's at a
kind of a factual level or at a
conceptual level is super valuable for
forming that critical thinking and so I
think there's always going to be a very
important place for having that core
knowledge and it will allow you to build
more connections and if you have that
some of that core knowledge you don't
have to apply as much of your cognitive
load when you have to do more complex
and tasks to those things you know one
way to think about it is you know you're
playing basketball or so let's say
you're learning a new sport let's say
you've never played basketball before
you can focus on the rules of the game
and maybe things movements that are new
to you like dribbling but you don't have
to think about things like walking or
jumping those are things you know how to
do already because they're so automatic
and there's analogs in the learning
world there you know in math something
like your core multiplication tables
it's of course important to understand
what multiplication really is or what
how it can be represented but if when
you're doing algebra you have to sit and
think wait is nine times six is it 54 is
it 56 that's going to make it very hard
for you to engage in the algebra or if
you are trying to think critically about
economic we'll talk a situation right
now if you're trying to think about well
what could be the economic implications
of this kovat crisis if you don't
already in the back of your mind have
context of saying okay well we've gone
through things like this before you have
the Great Depression which was in the
1930s and then okay what was the
historical context there how did we get
out of it well there was World War two
there was a great deal I started a new
deal and you could say well how much did
each of those things contribute if you
don't have some of that knowledge base
there it's very hard to think critic
about new situations so I'm a big
proponent and a lot of what we try to do
at Khan Academy is give you that
practice not just at the the most basic
level of you know facts but at the
conceptual level and at an understanding
comprehending level so that you build
that fluency that you so you can go
higher and higher up that that you know
it's often known as blooms cognitive
taxonomy blooms cognitive taxonomy of
skills so you can go higher and higher
on that so I I don't think it's an
either/or I think there's actually a
value to having some of that that core
that core knowledge so there's a
question from Pattie Prentiss on
Facebook hi I'm a college student will
the pandemic affect availability of
classes offered in the future I heard
that colleges and universities will
experience will have fewer students
because of the pandemic patty it's a
fascinating question I don't think I
definitely am NOT an expert here and I
have been talking to some university
administrators and people are familiar
and I don't think anyone really knows
how all of this will settle as you could
imagine we hope that we're through the
worst of the stay in place orders and
school closures as we go to back to
school and hopefully the colleges and
universities like K through 12 will be
able to open back up but you could
imagine that if if the virus goes starts
going at exponential again and starts
picking back up it might have to be
closed down again so it is going to be a
hard time for universities and there is
a situation where a lot of students are
saying hey well if the university is
going virtual maybe I can just stay
virtual so that some of that might
happen and there are things like virtual
universities and MOOCs and things like
that you know personally I found a lot
of value in the physical experience of
university that's where I met my wife
where I met some of my best friends that
I I talked about that I connect with on
a regular basis some of whom I even
helped start Khan Academy and help other
things so I think College is really
powerful from a social connection and
building yourself in many dimension
point of view but I think this crisis
does make us ask questions of like well
what aspects are nice to have what
aspects are must-haves and there's a
resourcing question College is
increasingly expensive and so are there
pathways that
be more flexible that can focus on the
must-haves and that could you know leave
students with a lot less debt you know
when we say we want we're not-for-profit
with the mission of a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere that's
because we don't think someone's
education should hold back their their
ability to be empowered in the world but
we know far too many people and I know
people even in my own family who the
debt they've incurred has been you know
somewhat debilitating actually for their
ability to participate in society
because of college so we'll see how all
of this plays out well anyway these were
great questions we will continue this
we're here every day at 12 p.m. Pacific
3 p.m. Eastern in the US or whatever
times when y'all are in Europe you can
figure it out it's a place for us to
just stay connected answer questions
about education the economy viruses
we're going to have we have exciting
slate of guests we're probably gonna
have two or three guests a week that are
are interesting and have expertise in
different areas and I'll just remind
everyone you know stay safe stay healthy
and if you're in a position to do so
please think about donating to Khan
Academy we need the help especially if
we're able to support more folks through
this crisis thank you
you